[موسيقى]
في سعيها المستمر منذ سنوات لاصلاح قواعد
اللجوء والهجره تمكنت دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي اخيرا من حسم خلافاتها والاتفاق
على نص رئيسي خاص باجراءات جديده للهجره
هذه الاجراءات تمنح الحق لاي دوله عضو
بالاتحاد في اتخاذ تدابير استثنائيه في
حاله الازمات او القوى القاهره مثل تدفق
اعداد كبيره من المهاجرين نحو حدودها كما
حدث اثناء ازمه اللاجئين عام
و26 الاتفاق الجديد يعتبر خطوه مهمه نحو
التوصل الى اتفاق اشمل وجعل التغييرات
ملزمه ملزمه عفوا قانونا قبل انتخاب
البرلمان الاوروبي العام المقبل فالى اي
حد سينجح الاتفاق الجديد في تحقيق اهدافه
الرئيسيه وفي مقدمتها الحد من تدفق
المهاجرين غير النظاميين باعداد كبيره وما
مدى تعاون دول الاتحاد مع المنظمات
الدوليه وبلدان المنشا والعبور في وقف
الانتهاكات التي يتعرض لها هؤلاء
المهاجرون اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه
من
[موسيقى]
سيناريوهات السلام عليكم منعطف تاريخي
وخطوه كبيره الى الامام هكذا وصف الاتفاق
الذي توصل اليه ممثلو دول الاتحاد الاوربي
في بروكسل والذي يمهد الطريق نحو مزيد من
المفاوضات من اجل الوصول الى اتفاق اوسع
واشمل بشان الهجره واللجوء لمعرفه مضامين
هذا الاتفاق وما اذا كان سيحقق لدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي الحمايه المنشوده
لحدودها الخارجيه والحد من تدفقات الهجره
غير النظاميه يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه
الحلقه من بروكسل هيلينا هان الخبيره في
شؤون اله جر بمركز السياسات الاوروبيه من
ميلانو في ايطاليا خالد شوقي النائب
السابق في البرلمان الايطالي والخبير في
شؤون الهجره ومن تونس العاصمه مالك
الخالدي الصحفي والناشط الحقوقي والمستشار
لدى منظمات دوليه بشان الهجره فاهلا بهم
جميعا لا يزال الاتحاد الاوروبي يواجه
مشكلات في التعامل مع ملف اللجوء والهجره
وبعد سنوات من الانقسامات والخلافات يبدو
ان الاتفاق الجديد سيحدث تحولا في سياسات
الاتحاد بهذا الشان من خلال تعديل قواعد
معينه على سبيل المثال فيما يتعلق بتسجيل
طلبات اللجوء او اجراءات اللجوء على
الحدود في جزيره لامبيدوزا الايطاليه يفوق
هؤلاء المهاجرون غير النظاميين سكان
الجزيره عددا ففي ايام معدودات خلال شهر
سبتمبر ايلول وصل نحو 100 الا مهاجر غير
نظامي الجزيره بينما يقل عدد سكانها اصلا
عن 7000 نسمه هنا في لامبيدوزا مختصر
القصه فالدول الاوروبيه المطله على البحر
المتوسط وعلى راسها ايطاليا تجد نفسها
جدار صد في مواجهه تدفق المهاجرين الى
القاره الاوروبيه لذلك شكل الاتفاق الذي
توصل اليه سفراء دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
قبيل قمه رؤساء الدول والحكومات في غرناطه
شكل اختراقا مهم من طال
انتظاره ينص الاتفاق على اعتماد نظام
استثنائي اقل حمايه لطالبي اللجوء من
الاجراءات المعتاده في حال حدوث تدفق
جماعي وغير مسبوق للمهاجرين ويمدد احتمال
احتجاز المهاجرين على الحدود الخارجيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لمده قد تصل الى 40
اسبوعا كما يسمح باجراء دراسه لطلبات
اللجوء بشكل اسرع ومبسط لعدد اكبر من
الوافدين للتمكن من اعادتهم سهوله وينص
الاتفاق على تفعيل سريع لاليات التضامن
بين الدول الاعضاء في رعايه اللاجئين لا
سما باعاده توطين طالبي اللجوء او تقديم
مساهمه ماليه للدول التي تتحمل هذا العب
يشكل التوصل الى هذا الاتفاق اختراقا لانه
كان مثار جدل ومحور خلاف كبير بين ايطاليا
والمانيا تشدد برلين على الجوانب
الانسانيه قالت وزيره خارجيتها ان بك ان
بلادها ناضلت حتى الدقيقه الاخيره لتجنب
تمييع المعايير الانسانيه المتعلقه مثلا
بحق اللاجئين في التعليم والرعايه
الصحيه وكانت ايطاليا تنتقد بشده تمويل
المانيا لعدد من منظمات الاغاثه التي كانت
تنفذ عمليات انقاذ المهاجرين في المتوسط
وتق تدهم الى السواحل الايطاليه تحاجج
روما بان على الدول التي تنتمي اليها هذه
منظمات ان تنقل المهاجرين الى اراضيها وعد
الخلاف الايطالي الالماني شهد تصويت
السفراء على الاتفاق يوم الاربعاء امتناع
كل من النمسه وسلوفاكيا وتشيك بينما
عارضته بولندا والمجره تتحفظ هذه الدول
على تخيرها بين تقديم التزامات باعاده
توطين عدد من اللاجئين في اراضيها او
حتميه تقديم مساهمات ماليه للدول التي
تعيد
توطينهم
ما زال الاتفاق بصيغته الحاليه بحاجه الى
موافقه البرلمان الاوروبي لكن ما كان يهم
الحكومات الاوروبيه اكثر قد حدث وهو تحقيق
التوافق على التشريعات الجديده قبل موعد
الانتخابات البرلمانيه الاوروبيه منتصف
العام المقبل ففي ظل صعود احزاب اليمين
المتطرف المعاديه للهجره في كثير من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي تبدو مساعي الحكومات
لاقرار تشريعات الهجره واللجوء سباقا مع
الزمن وبالاضافه الى الاجراءات التي اتفق
عليها من قبل ممثلي دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
في بروكسل اتخذت الحكومه الالمانيه تدابير
جديده للحد من الهجره غير النظاميه وقد
اثارت هذه التدابير جدلا وانتقادات حاده
من اللاجئين ونشطاء حقوق الانسان الذين
قالوا انها تتضمن اجراءات من شانها ان
تؤدي الى انتهاكات خطيره لحقوق
الانسان
من بين الاجراءات التي اعلنتها الحكومه
الالمانيه القيام بعمليه تفتيش مؤقته على
الحدود عند المعابر مع بولندا وتشيك ووقف
القبول الطوعي للاجئين القديمين من
ايطاليا كما اعلنت خطه لتجديد قوانين
الترحيل ما قد يؤدي الى سجن المهاجرين غير
نظاميين ومن بين الاجراءات التي انتقدها
ناشطون في مجال حقوق الانسان امكانيه
القبض على اللاجئ والتحكم بهاتفه وجمع
المعلومات عنها وقد رفضت الحكوم الالمانيه
هذه الانتقادات وقالت ان اجراءاتها
الاخيره تهدف الى مكافحه تهريب المهاجرين
على الحدود ودعت برلين بقيه الدول الاعضاء
بالاتحاد الاوروبي لتقاسم الاعباء بشكل
عادل بين الدول وتعتبر المانيا الوجهه
الاولى للمهاجرين غير النظاميين وطالبي
اللجوء الذين يصلون الى دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقد تقدم نحو 205000 مهاجر بطلب
لجوء في المانيا بين يناير واغسطس من
العام الجاري اي ما يمثل زياده بنسبه
77% مقارنه بالمده نفسها من العام الماضي
ووفق السلطات سيقيم حاليا ما يقدر بنحو 28
الف مهاجر وطالب لجوء في المانيا دون
تصريح اقامه سار المفعول في حين يبلغ عدد
المهاجرين الذين يمكن ترحيلهم بشكل فوري
نحو 54 الف بحسب الارقام
الرسميه نرحب بضيوفنا من جديد ونبدا من
بروكسل والسيده هيلينا هان اهلا وسهلا بك
هذا الاتفاق الاوروبي الاخير حول الهجره
هل فعلا يمكن ان يحد من تدفق المهاجرين
كما يامل
الاوروبيون مساء الخير وشكرا على
الاستضافه في
البرنامج اذا هذا الاتفاق الذي تم التوصل
اليه في هذا الاسبوع هو في الحقيقه مجرد
خطوه واحده ولكنه ليس الخلاصه النهائيه
لهذا الميثاق الجديد حول اللجوء والهجره
لانه
وكما جرى ذكره وجدت دول الاعضاء موقفا
مشتركا ولكنها بحاجه الى الدخول في
مفاوضات مع البرلمان الاوروبي وليس واضحا
بعد ما اذا كان الاتحاد الاوروبي سوف يكون
لديه نظام جديد للجوء ربما يحصل ذلك في
السنه المقبله او ربما
فان المؤسسات في الاتحاد الاوروبي قد لا
تتوصل الى اتفاق بالنظر الى مدى صعوبه
التوصل حتى الى هذه الخطوه البسيطه
بالنسبه الى التدفقات وموجات الهجره
بالنسبه الى هذا النظام الجديد من القواعد
فهو لا يوقف تدفق المهاجرين ولكنه يحسن
اداره هذه
التدفقات الاهم هو انلا ننسى ان الفكره
ليست وضع حد نهائي تدفق المهاجرين الى
اوروبا بل تحسين تدفقهم من اجل تلبيه
حاجات معظما ياتون الى اوروبا سواء كانوا
طالبي الجوء بحاجه لحمايه الدوليه او حتى
من يسعون الى فرص اقتصاديه في اوروبا ولكن
سيده هان عندما يقول المستشار الالماني
شولز بان هذا تحول تاريخي وسيحد بشكل فعال
من قدوم المهاجرين والسيده فوندر لاين
تقول بانه سي سيغير قواعد اللعبه هل في
هذا
مبالغه سوف تتغير القواعد اذا كانت الدول
الاعضاء والبرلمان الاوروبي قادره على
التوصل الاتفاق حول القواعد المشتركه سوف
يغيرون النظام كما هو الان ولكن في نهايه
المطاف على اوروبا ان تجد وسيله وسبيلا ل
تعامل مع الهجره ليست مساله وقف الهجره
تماما او ايقاف المهجرين عند الحدود
الهجره تحصل والناس يتحركون وينتقلون
لاسباب مختلفه هذه الرزمه هي بمثابه وسيله
او طريقه لايجاد استجابه لهذه الحركيه
ولكن التركيز كما نجده الان هو على الحد
من الحركه
وحراسه الحدود اذا زياده الامور صعوبه
بالنسبه الى دخول هؤلاء الى
اوروبا ستستمر المفاوضات لاننا نعرف ان
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في مواجهه البرلمان
الاوروبي قد اتخذت اذا
مواقف مقيده في معظم الملفات التي تمت
مناقشتها طبعا عن عندما نقول التشدد في
موضوع الهجره سيد خالد شوقي في ميلانو
عاده ما تذكر ايطاليا بحكومتها الحاليه
على الاقل مثل هذا الاتفاق هل
يرضيها نعم بالتاكيد لان ايطاليا حاولت ان
تضغط على اوروبا وهذا كان محور صراع مع
المانيا فيما يخص اول شيء محاوله اقصاء
المنظمات الانسانيه من البحر الابيض
المتوسط التي قامت بدور مهم جدا في انقاذ
الالاف من اللاجئين من الغرق ومن الموت
الاكيد وهذه هي المقاربه الامنيه التي طرت
على هذا الاتفاق حسب
بحيث هناك محاوله لتقليص مجموعه من
الضمانات التي كانت من قبل موفره لطالبي
اللجوء والمهاجرين بصفه عامه حين وصولهم
الى اوروبا ولكن بهذه الخطوه هناك اظن
محاوله لتقليص تلك الضمانات والتناقض مع
مجموعه
من الحقوق التي مضمونه على مستوى
الاتفاقيات الدوليه وهذا ما اعترضت عليه
مجموعه من المنظمات الانسانيه اليوم فهناك
غبه اظن للمفوضين الاوروبيه في ان تثبت ان
هناك محاوله
لايقاف موجات اللاجئين للوافدين الى
اوروبا من خلال ربما خطوات غير معلنه بشكل
واضح ولكن هذا هو المسار وما قامت به
المانيا مباشره بعد ذلك من قوانينها
الداخليه في اعاده النظر في مجموعه من
القوانين للتعامل مع اللاجئين هذا اكبر
تعبير على هذا التوجه الاوروبي بصفه عامه
الذي تطغى عليه خطاب يميني وخصوصا ونحن
على ابواب انتخابات اوروبيه التي سيكون
موضوع الهجره كالعاده محور اساسي فيها
والتناقض الاساسي الذي نلاحظه ان في
الاتفاق يعني يطرح موضوع التضامن الاوروبي
ولكن في نفس الوقت الدول الاوروبيه في ما
بينها قد تلغي شنغن بحيث هناك مراقبه
اليوم على الحدود بين ايطاليا وفرنسا
وايطاليا والنمس والمانيا ودول الجنوب
ولكن ولكن مجرد تقليس الضمانات سيد شوقي
هل هل سيثبت من عزيمه هؤلاء المهاجرين
هؤلاء عندما يركبون البحر لا يفكرون كثيرا
في ان الضمانات قلصت في في في اوروبا سيغا
امر كما فعل في
السابق هي هناك جزء من الاتفاق الذي لم
يتم ربما اعلان الاشهار به بشكل كبير وهذا
اضن ليس
ليس عفوي ولكن
هناك ظروف سياسيه في اوروبا التي تجعل من
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان لا يتحدث عنها كثيرا
وهي ملف طبعا التعاون الدولي ومحاربه
اسباب الهجره و وضع اتفاقيات مع
دول الوفود ودول المعبر وهذه المحاوله
مثلا التي كانت بين اوروبا وبين تونس و
حتى الان لم تحضى بالنجاح فهناك جزء من
تلك السياسات التي تطرح ايضا في هذا
الاتفاق وهذا هو الاصل وليس فقط المقاربه
الامنيه ونحن نلاحظ ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
اليوم عاجز على ان يجد
اتفاقيات عادله ومع فرقاء ورؤساء الدول
الافريقيه فهذا هو الجزء الذي ربما
ينبغي دعمه بقوه والاستثمار فيه بشكل بشكل
قوي طبعا هناك اشكالات كبيره مثل من
المحاوره في الضفه الجنوبيه ونحن نعلم ان
مجموعه من تلك الدول الافريقيه اليوم تعيش
مجمو من الاضطرابات
وايضا هناك محاوله
لربما التخويف من الهجره مباشره عبر وسائل
الاعلام الافريقيه فهناك خطه اعلاميه
اليوم قامت بها رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
مثلا في الاعلام التونسي بشكل مباشر بحيث
تحاول ان تنصح شباب تونسين في ان لا
يغامروا لانهم اذا غامروا فسيجدون ابوابا
مغلقه واستعداد لايطاليا بان ترجعهم الى
بلادهم فهناك خطاب ايضا يعني شبه عنصري ول
لكن هو خطاب حاد لاول مره من اوروبا موجه
لشباب الافارقه بحيث ينصحهم بعدم المغامره
والمخاطره لان سيواجهون بقوانين صائمه ليس
مثل الماضي نعم طالما ذكرت تونس دائما
تونس سيد مالك الخالدي تذكر في هذه
الموجات الاخيره من من الهجره الى ايطاليا
وتذكر ليبيا ايضا ولكن تونس ربما بشكل خاص
هذه التدابير الجديده او التدابير
الاستثنائيه كيف يمكن ان تستقبل في بلد
مثل تس
مثلا شكرا على
الاستضافه الشباب التونسي والراغبين في
الهجره الى الفضاء الاوروبي وبعد غلق كل
المنافذ خاصه في التقليص من حصص تونس ودول
المغرب العربي كذلك في حصص الحصول على
التاشيرات نحو الفضاء الاوروبي لا يهمه
المهاجر اليوم ان كان او كانت دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي تشدد من اجراءاتها الداخليه ام
لا تضع مثلا مبلغ 5000 اورو مثل ما هذا
الاجراء الذي وضعته مؤخرا ميلوني في
ايطاليا اما الاحتجاج او دفع
5000 اورو المهاجر لا تهمه كل هذه المسائل
في تونس صحيح ان المهاجر يعرف بعض
التفاصيل ولكن هناك هدف واحد من العديد من
المهاجرين هو والذهاب نحو ايطاليا وخاصه
الوجهه الاولى اليوم
هي الجزيره الموجوده وهي جزيره لامبيدوزا
التي تبعد 188 ر على تونس
فمنظمة نقلهم الى الفضاء الاوروبي اذا كل
التفاصيل التي تتحدث عن اجراءات وتجديدها
وهذا شبه اتفاق يعتبر ما تم الاتفاق عليه
من سفراء الاتحاد الاوروبي هو شبه اتفاق
ينتظر موافقه البرلمان الاوروبي ولا اعتقد
في الحقيقه ان بقبول مثل هذه الاجراءات
خاصه عندما نفرق ما بين المهاجر واللاجئ
وطالب اللجوء اليوم المهاجرين عندما يتم
انقاذهم في عرض البحر اول شيء يقوم به
المهاجر هو تقديم طلب اللجوء اذا اليوم
عندما تريد او يريد الاتحاد الاوروبي من
تغيير او تجديد هذه الاجراءات عليه ان
يخرج
ويستنكر او يتنكر عفوا من اتفاقيه
1951 لوضع اللاجئين والبروتوكول المتمم
لها لسنه 67 وهي اتفاقيات امميه صارمه
موقعه من قبل العديد من الدول ومنها ايضا
تونس ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم لا ننسى
ان هناك مجلس اوروبا ولا ننسى ايضا لجنه
البندقيه التي تنظر كذلك في مدى تطابق هذه
الاجراءات مع حقوق الانسان و ومع
ايضا
القوانين وكن مع ذلك سي سيد خالدي
يعني يعني مثلا وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
تحدثت عن انه لن يتم اللجوء الى هذه
التدابير الا في الحالات القسوى ويجب ان
تكون في حالات مبرره و وبشكل مقنع للغايه
وبانها سعت قدر الامكان هي تقول عن عن عن
بلادها على الاقل بان بان لا تكون هذه
التدابير الاستثنائيه قاسيه وان تراعي على
الاقل الحق في الصحه والحق في التعليم هذا
لا يكفي
كتطبيق مينات لان ما هي الحالات القاسيه
وهنا ليس هناك توضيح من هذه الحكومات هناك
محاوله لارضاء في الحقيقه جورجيا ميلوني
بعد زياره جزيره لامبيدوزا الايطاليه
وقبول يعني ووضع اللاجئين هناك ووضع
المهاجرين هناك محاوله لارضاء جورج ميلوني
التي تحاول فعلا استقبال كل المهاجرين
جميعا وهناك ايضا نقد لاضع من جورج ميلوني
الى فرنسا التي اليوم خالفت القوانين او
قوانين الاتحاد الاوروبي بمنع مهاجرين من
المرور من اطاليا الى فرنسا مثلا هنا
المانيا تريد ارضاء جورجيا ميلوني وجورجيا
ميلوني من جهه اخرى تريد ايضا كسب مرحله
سياسيه بكونها
زعيمه التيار اليميني كل الامور استاذ
محمد مترابطه فيما بينها والوضع صحيح ان
هناك تقريبا تقديرات 133 الف تقريبا مهاجر
نحو الفضاء الاوروبي وخاصه نحو ايطاليا
ولكن كل هذه التطمينات لا تكفي على اوروبا
اليوم ان تضع مقاييس واضحه تكون وفق
المعايير الدوليه المتعارف عليها في
اتفاقيات الامم المتحده وانها لن تخالف كل
هذا نذكر فقط بقرار قاضي في سيقل مؤخرا
بكونه رفض مرسوم لجورجيا ميلوني بسجن
تونسي او دفع خطيه ماليه مع كذلك وجود
مراكز احتجاز اقولها مراكز احتجاز تم
انشاؤها بطريقه سريعه في ايطاليا وهناك
خطوه نحو الذهاب الى هذه التجربه في دول
اخرى اوروبيه هو على ذكر على ذكر ايطاليا
وتونس يعني الارقام تقول انه حتى الرابع
من من اكتوبر هذا العام وصل الى اجمالي من
وصل الى ايطاليا فوق
135 الف الجنسيات الثلاث الاولى الغنيين
وا من ساحل العاج من كوت ديفوار ومن تونس
هذه الجنسيات الثلاثه على كل بينما تتواصل
المفاوضات بشان ازمه الهجره واللجوء بين
الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي كشفت
منظمه الامم المتحده الطفول المعنيه
بالطفوله اليونيسيف ان عدد المهاجرين
الذين لقوا حتفهم او فقدوا في خلال عبورهم
البحر المتوسط في الصيف العام الجاري
ارتفع ثلاث مرات مقارنه بنفس الفتره من
العام الماضي معتبره ان البحر المتوسط بات
مقبره
للاطفال سجلت منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله
اليونيسيف غرق ما لا يقل عن 990 شخصا
بينهم اطفال في البحر المتوسط بين يونيو
واغسطس من عام
2023 ما يعادل ثلاثه اضعاف ما سجل في
الفتره نفسها من عام
2022 ومنذ يناير
2023 توفي اكثر من
20089 طفلا خلال عمليات عبور البحر اكثر
من
11600 قاصر حاولوا التوجه الى ايطاليا من
دون ذويهم بين يناير ومنتصف سبتمبر الماضي
بزياده 60% مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من العام
الماضي ريجينيا دي دومس المنسقه لدى
اليونيسيف قالت ان البحر المتوسط بات
مقبره للاطفال وان العدد الماساوي للاطفال
الذين يموتون خلال سعيهم للحصول على الامن
والملجا في اوروبا كان نتيجه الخيارات
السياسيه ونظام هجره فاشل مفوضيه الامم
المتحده الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين ذكرت خلال
اجتماع لمجلس الامن مخصص للازمه في
المتوسط ان اكثر من 2500 مهاجر قضوا او
فقدوا بين يناير وسبتمبر من العام الجاري
بزياده 50% عن العام الماضي الحرب
والصراعات والعنف والفقر عوامل تدفع
الاطفال الى الفرار من اوطانهم وحدهم فقد
احصت اليونيسيف وجود نحو
21700 طفل غير مصحوبين بذويهم في مراكز
ايواء اللاجئين في ايطاليا وصول اكثر من
8500 شخص الى جزيره لامبيدوسا الايطاليه
خلال ثلاثه ايام اي اكثر من عدد سكانها
اثار ازمه محليه وعاصفه سياسيه في
ايطاليا
سيده هن ارقام مخيفه تابعناها كما تذكرها
اليونيسيف يبدو ان الاتفاق الاخير لم يعد
معنيا كثيرا بمساله الهجره كم مساله
انسانيه يجب ان تعالج ببعد شمولي يبدو ان
التوجه الان هو توجه نحو مزيد من الضغط في
الاجراءات بغ بهدف اثناء الناس عن عن
القدوم اكثر منها معالجه للظاهره ككل
ان مذكره التفاهم بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتونس التي وقعت مؤخرا طبعا في بداياتها
ومراحلها المبكره وما وصفتم بالنسبه الى
التزايد مرده عدد من العوامل طبعا ندرك ان
المساله الموسميه مهمه حيث ان الظروف
المناخيه ربما هي التي شجعت المزيد من
الاشخاص لكي يحاولوا ربما اكثر من مره
الوصول الى شط اوروبا في الوقت
نفسه نتوقع ان توقيع مذكره التفاهم
والاجراءات التي تشملها او تتبعها مثل
زياده او تشديد حراسه الحدود ربما ايضا
ادت الى ممارسه المزيد من الضغوط حيث قرر
كثر ان يحاولوا ان يصلوا بينما لا تزال
الفرصه سانحه لذلك الى ذلك لا نزل نشهد
تاثيرات مرحله ما بعد جائحه كورونا
حيث ان
سنتين التين شهدنا فيها الجائحه لا يمكن
ان تعتبر معيارا للمقارنه هذه العوامل
وغيرها تطلع
بدور او تعتبر مبررا ل هذه الاعداد وفي
الوقت نفسه فيما يتعلق بالوفيات
والحالات الاختفاء التي نشهدها لهؤلاء
المهاجرين سببها هو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومنذ سنتين قرر
ان يوقف مهمته في المتوسط وحيث صار يقوم
فقط بعمليات مراقبه جويه وترك ثغره بناء
عليه حيث ان حرس الحدود المحليه او الوطني
طبعا يقوم
بمراقبته ولكن عددا قليلا من المنظمات غير
الحكوميه هي التي تجري عمليات البحث
والانقاذ اذا هناك غياب على المستوى
الاوروبي لتنسيق هذه العمليات مما ادى الى
زياده الوفيات ولكن البعد القانوني سيده
هيلن هان مهم جدا يعني منظمه العفو
الدوليه انتقدت هذا الاتفاق الاخير
الاوروبي اعتبرت بان حرمان الاشخاص الذين
يطلبون الوجو من حقوقهم امر خطير هكذا
وصفته واعتبرت بانه يقوض الحقوق
الاساسيه العزف على وتيره الحقوق وحقوق
الانسان ان صح التعبير هل يمكن ان يكون
حجر عثره في طريق تطبيق هذا الاتفاق خاصه
عندما يعرض على البرلمان
الاوروبي نعم نعم بالفعل عبر السنوات
بالنسبه الى البرلمان الاوروبي فيما يتعلق
بالهجره وايضا موضوع مساعدات التنميه
لطالما كان لديه موقف
متشدد فيما يتعلق بحقوق الانسان اما في
المفاوضات فقد حاول ان يضمن ان حقوق
المهاجرين وطالبي اللجوء محميه ومضمونه
وكما اسلفت فان الدول
الاعضاء سعت اكثر فاكثر الى فرض اجراءات
مقيده وخي وضوابط
لتاخير اذا النظر في طلبات الجوء على
الحدود الخارجيه واحيانا فرد اجراءات
للاحتجاز اذا هناك حماس لدى سياسيين من
الاطراف اليمينيه من اجل الابتعاد عن
المقاربه المتعلقه بحقوق الانسان في سياسه
الهجره وهذا ما رايناه يتحول الى مشكله في
مذكره تتفاهم مع
تونس حيث ان المفوضيه الاوروبيه بالاضافه
الى هولندا وايطاليا
قاضت جهود لتصل الى هذا الاتفاق الرسمي
دعونا لا ننسى ان هذه الاتفاقات غير رسميه
وتبقى معرضه للكثير من الهشاشه هي ضعيفه
غير ملزمه ولا تؤدي الى اي طبيعات صارمه
او مؤث اذا قرر احد الاطراف عدم الالتزام
بهذه بالتعهدات ما نشهده هنا هو غياب
للشفافيه وهذا قد ادى الى صرخه من
البرلمان الاوروبي وغيره من الاطراف لانهم
يقولون اذا اردنا ان نتعاون مع دول من
خارج الاتحاد الاوروبي علينا الحرص على
احترام حقوق الانسان بما يكفي ضمن هذه
الاتفاقات هو مثلا اتفاق تونس السيد خالد
شوقي الذي اشرت اليه السيده هيليان تعرض
لانتقادات شديده من من اطراف اوروبيه في
حين انه عندما تم توقيعه كان ينظر اليه من
ايطاليا ومن تونس على الاقل على انه يمكن
ان يشكل نموذج للاخرين
حتى مفاوضه الاتحاد الاوروبي اعربت عن نفس
الامل لكن يبدو ان هناك نوع من الخيبه
الامل في هذا الموضوع
الان بالتاكيد ان كان يعول كثيرا على هذا
الاتفاق خصوصا وان تونس تعتبر من الدول
التي في السنوات الماضيه كان تعتبر حليف
لاوروبا لايطاليا بشكل خاص فيما يخص هذا
النوع من الاتفاقيات الذي يعبر عن مصالح
مشتركه فتونس
تستلم موارد ماديه ل من جزء منها ينبغي ان
يوجه للتنميه والاقتصاد وجزء اخر طبعا
لتقويه جهاز مكافحه الهجره غير الشرعيه
وفي المقابل
ايطاليا تفتح قنوات للدخول الشرعي لفئات
معينه من الشباب التونسيين وهذا فعلا ما
يحصل ولكن بارقام دائله جدا طبعا هناك
اليوم اشاره فيما يخص موضوع حقوق الانسان
ف تونس كما نعلم لا تريد التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه في وضع شروط وهذا هذا هذه النقطه
هي ربما ما تزعج مجموعه من البرلمانيين
الاوربيين اليوم الذين يريدون ان يربط هذا
النوع من الاتفاق مع الشؤون الداخليه
التونسيه في هذه الفتره بشكل خاص انا
اعتقد ان لا لا وسيله الا من خلال هذا
النوع من الاتفاقيات طبعا لاوروبا اوروبا
لا يمكن ان تختار من يمثل الشعوب
الافريقيه والعكس صحيح ولهذا فا اذا كانت
الاولويه اليوم هي الحد او على الاقل
تنظيم الهجره من افريقيا الى الى الى
اوروبا فينبغي وضع
كنقطه اساسيه وضع مبدا الاحترام المتبادل
والاتفاقيات العادله فلا يمكن
ان تطلب اوروبا من هذه الدول ان تكون
شرطيا لها على حدود على اراضيها من غير ان
تضمن ايضا وسائل شرعيه لوفود الالاف من
الشباب التي اوروبا اصلا تحتاج اليهم نحن
نعلم اليوم ان ايطاليا والمانيا مثلا من
بين الدول على مستوى العالم التي تعاني من
الشيخوخه هناك اليوم الكثير كثير من مراكز
الشغل ورجال الاعمال الاوروبي الذين
يعانون من ضعف اليد العامله ولهذا فا
اوروبا تحتاج لكفاءات من افريقيا ولكن
طبعا ينبغي ان يكون هذا المسار من خلال
برامج متفق عليها من خلال قنوات مثلما
تفعل مثلا امريكا وكندا او فعلت المانيا
مع مع اللاجئين السوريين ولكن هذه
الاحتياجات اليوم كل القياديين السياسيين
يعلمون بها ولكن هناك نفاق واضح في حيث لا
ليس لهم الجوه في ان خاطب شعوبهم ورايهم
العام ومن يصوت عليهم بان هذه هي
الحقيقه مثلا مع تونس ما الذي جعل
الامور تتعثر يعني الان في انتكاسه في هذا
الاتفاق حتى ان الرئيس قيس سعيد رفض ما
اعتبره صدقه او منه في الدفعه اخيره ب 42
مليون يورو وبالتالي فكل الاتفاق
تقريبا
تعثر
لان الالتزام من طرف الاتحاد الاوروبي
وخصوصا من المانيا وفرنسا كان هو الضغط
على البنك الدولي لكي يعطي الضوء الاخضر
لتمويل اكبر يعتبر بمليار او 200 مليون لو
لم تخني الذاكره ولهذا ف اوروبا لم تفي
بعهدها في ان تضغط على الولايات المتحده
وعلى وهذا ما اشير اليه في الجلسه الاخيره
للامم المتحده في نيويورك فهناك هنا عدم
التزام من طرف الاتحاد الاوروبي في الضغط
بما يكفي من البنك الاوروبي الى البنك
الدولي
لاعطاء هذا القرض المهم والحيوي بالنسبه
للمستقبل مستقبل استقرار تونس كدوله ولهذا
ف الرئيس تونسي رفض هذا النوع
من من التناقض وهذه الصدقه كما اشار اليها
واعتبر ان من حق دوله مثل تونس اليوم ان
لا تتنا
عن مجموعه من الالتزامات الاوروبيه مقابل
ان تكون
شرطيه لاوروبا وخدومه للحملات الانتخابيه
الاوروبيه ينبغي ان يعلم الاوروبيين اليوم
بان موضوع الهجره ليس موضوع مرتبط بحدود
وانما هو موضوع يرتبط بمستقبل الانسانيه
ككل ومستقبل كل المتوسط ولهذا ف ايضا
الطلب من دول مثل فرنسا مثلا في عدم تدخل
في شؤون بعض الدول وهذه كانت اشاره من
جورجا ملوني ومن من مجموعه من الدول اعاده
نظر في كيفيه برامج التنميه في بعض الدول
الافريقيه هذه هي المحاوله الاساسيه التي
ينبغي ان ينتبه
اليها وربما وربما هذا ربما هذا التدهور
في في في العلاقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتونس السيد مالك الخالدي من من
تونس فسر البعض انه التدفق الاخير لاعداد
اللاجئين من تونس هو نوع من الاعراب عن
الاحباط التونسي من هذا الموضوع والبعض
الاخر راه حتى محاوله للضغط على الاتحاد
الاوروبي اتفاق مع تونس هو الاتفاق الوحيد
ومع ذلك لا تسير الامور بشكل جيد ما
المطروح في
النهايه هناك ال ما بني نحن في القانون
نقول ما بني على باطل فهو باطل يعني الذه
قاعده عامه في في
القانوني مجرد مذكره تفاهم وهذه مذكره
تفاهم لا ترتقي الى مستوى الاتفاقيات لذلك
بنيت هشه بنيت ضعيفه لم تكن لديها لا
شرعيه كبيره داخل البرلمان الاوروبي وداخل
كل اعضاء الاتحاد الاوروبي ولم تكن ايضا
لديها شرعيه داخل حتى تونس ولم يصادق
عليها كذلك البرلمان التونسي ولم يشارك
حتى في صياغتها كافه مجتمع المدني افراد
المجتمع المدني والمجتمع السياسي في تونس
اذا هناك العديد من المشاكل الشكليه
والشرعيه في هذه الاتفاقيه ثانيا هناك
تصريحات الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون في
حواره الاخير الذي تحدث عن امكانيه ارسال
مراقبين وامكانيه مراقبه الحدود من خلال
اليات ومن خلال خفر سواحل امنيه لمراقبه
الحدود رات في تونس ان هذا تدخل في
سيادتها ومراقبه لحدودها وتدخل حتى في
عمليات وصلاحياتها الداخليه كذلك ان هناك
التعامل ليس ال بند يعني عندما تحدث عن
امكانيه ان تقوم او يقوم الاتحاد الاوروبي
بصرف 127 مليون اورو وهو مبلغ
زهيد جدا الى اين يتوجه هذا المبلغ الذي
صرفه المفاوضيه الاوروبيه سيتوجه الى الى
مراقبه الحدود الى عوده المساعده في عوده
العوده القصريه للمهاجرين من الفضاء
الاوروبي ومراقبه الحدود ومساعده المنظمات
الاغاثه عرض البحر اذا لم تتضمن حتى
مساعدات في اطار دفع الميزانيه التونسيه
ونحن نعرف ان تونس اليوم تعاني من ازمه
اقتصاديه هذا ما جعل هذا
الاتفاق ممكن لا يحمل ولم يرضي التونسيين
كما لم يرضي ايضا الاوروبيين لان ايضا
اوروبا تنظر الى مساله حقوق الانسان
والتصريحات الرئيس التونسي في خلال هذه
السنه اثارت ضجه كبيره وتساؤلات و ايضا
رفض وفد من من المفوضيه الاوروبيه في احدى
اللجان لزياره تونس كل هذه المسائل بين
مقاربه حقوق الانسان والمساله السياسيه
كلها جعل هذا الملف وهه مذكره التفاهم
لنحدد كل هذه المفاهيم بطريقه صريحه لم
تنجح الى حدود هذه اللحظه واعتقد انها لن
تنجح مستقبل لسبب وحيد فقط ان كل ما هو
يتعلق بحقوق الانسان عندما نضعه على طاوه
السياسه فهو يفشل وتكون هناك انحرافات
بهذه الملفات كل ما هو انساني عليه ان
يطرح داخل كل الاتفاقيات الامميه
الاتفاقيات الثنائيه باحترام كل حقوق
الانسان وخاصه حقوق الفئات المستضعفه
والهشه داخل المجتمعات من مهاجرين ومن
لاجئين وطالبي لجوء وخاصه عندما نتحدث عن
اطفال وعن نساء كل هذه الملفات وكل هذه
النقاط من سياسيه الى اجتماعيه الى
انسانيه الى الانحراف بالملف من انساني
الى سياسي جعل هذا الاتفاق يفشل والاكيد
انه لن يحد من تدفق الهجره غير نظاميه بل
زاد من عمليه التدفقات والارقام واضحه في
حدود 135 ال
مهاجر نحو الفضاء الاوروبي منها من من
تونس ومنها من دول اخرى في نهايه الحلقه
نقوم بجوله بين ضيوفنا الثلاثه بسؤال عن
رؤيتهم للمستقبل هذا الاتفاق الاخير
للاتحاد الاوروبي بخصوص الهجره ما مصيره
في النهايه في ضوء هذه الاشكالات
المتداخله منها ما يتعلق بال الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومنها ما يتعلق بالعلاقه مع دول
الضفه الجنوبيه للمتوسط ما هي التوقعات
نبدا بالسيده هيلينا
هان كما سمعنا من قبل الضيوف الكرام فان
مذكره التفاهم هذه ضعيفه في الكثير من
الجوانب و وبالتالي القول انها قد تكون
لاتفاقات
مستقبليه ليس او ليست حجه مقنعه كذلك
علينا ان لا
ننسى ان اتفاقات التعاون السابقه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع تركيا ومع ليبيا طبعا
كانت مختلفه ولكن تونس في هذه الحاله يبدو
انها شريك لا يمكن الوثوق به والاعتماد
عليه بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي الذي دائما
سوف يسع على ما يبدو هذه الشراكات ل
معالجه موضوع الهجره لا سما عبر القنوات
الدبلوماسيه هناك سؤال مطروح حول ما اذا
كانت هذه الخطوات سوف ترتد عليه لان هذه
الاتفاقيه ليست موثوقه وكذلك سوف يكون
هناك تدقيق اكثر صرامه من البرلمان
الاوروبي وكذلك من البرلمانات الوطنيه
والجهات الموجوده في المجتمع المدني بحسب
ما ارى فان الاتحاد الاوروبي وعدد من
الدول الاعضاء فيها لا سما ايطالي فتستمر
في هذه الدبلوماسيه حول الهجره لانها تعوض
عن غياب الوحده والصف الواحد داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن في الوقت نفسه حتى لو كانت
الدول الاعضاء والبرلمان الاوروبي قادره
على التوصل الى اتفاق حول ميثاق اللجوء
والهجره الذي يتم التفاوض عليه الان فان
التركيز على شركات في موضوع الهجره سوف
يستمر لان هناك ايمان راسخ بانها سوف تنجح
او انه سوف ينجح حتى لو اثبت عدم فعاليته
في الكثير من الحالات سيد خالد
شوقي انا اعتقد ان هذا الاتفاق سيكون
مصيره مثل
الاتفاقات السابقه بحيث اوروبا ليست قادره
اليوم على تضامن فعلي على مستوى احتواء
اللاجئين بشكل متكافئ بين كل الدول هناك
دول اوروبا الشرقيه التي كما راينا حتى في
هذا القرار رفضت وكانت ضد هذا النوع من
الاتفاق هناك دول اسكندنافيه وهولندا بشكل
خاص التي ترفض الهجره فاظن انهم اجتمعوا
في هذه الفتره فقط لمصالح الانتخابيه
لاعطاء على الاقل رؤوس الاقلام وبعض
العناوين اما في المستقبل فسيكون الوضع هو
البحث عن اتفاقيات ثنائيه بين الول مثل
ايطاليا وتونس بشكل مباشر وهناك ايضا
تنافس اوروبي بين ايطاليا وفرنسا بشكل خاص
على مجموعه من الدول الافريقيه مثل الازمه
في ليبيا ومثل النيجر ومالي بحيث هناك
صراعات تحت الطاوله بين الحلفاء
الاوروبيين ولهذا فاعتقد ان هذا الاتفاق
ربما استطاعوا اليوم في اسبانيا في ان
يعلنوا عن الوصول الى الى هذا الحل ولكن
في الواقع امام اول ازمه تدفق جديده
سنلاحظ ان ستكون هناك نفس الاشكالات في
عدم التضامن الفعلي مع ايطاليا بشكل خاص
وهذا هو مصير اوروبا في غياب سياسه
اوروبيه خارجيه مشتركه هل معنى ذلك التوصل
الى تصور اوروبي مشترك تقريبا يكاد يصبح
مستحيلا سيكون هناك اتفاق
داخلي له بعد امني اكثر مما هو بعد حقوقي
وهذا هو التوجه الذي اصبحنا نلاحظه الان
هناك ايضا طلبات مهمه من شخصيات حتى من
الراي العام الاوروبي اليوم تطالب باعاده
النظر في مفهوم اللجوء اصلا والفرق بين
اللجوء السياسي واللجوء الاقتصادي فعلى
مستوى الداخلي اعتقد انه سيكون هناك تراجع
ك كبير جدا في مساله الحقوق وخصوصا ونحن
الان امام ضعف واضح لليسار الديمقراطي
الذي كان هو دائما الذي يدافع عن هذه
المبادئ اما على مستوى الخارجي فسيكون
هناك ربما البحث عن اتفاقيات ثنائيه بين
دول اوروبيه ودول افريقيه وهذا ما حاولت
ان تفعله ايطاليا ودول مثل المانيا بحيث
تجمع ما بين التضامن من اجل التنميه وفي
نفس الوقت مكافحه الهجره غير الشرعيه كما
هو جاري اليوم مثلا بين اسبانيا والمغرب
بين ايطاليا وليب والاتفاقيات التي تسع
اليها بعض الدول
الاوروبيه سيد مالك
الخالدي بالنسبه الى البرلمان الاوروبي
الذي سينظر قريبا في هذا الاتفاق الشبه
الاتفاق هناك قاعده انسانيه على اوروبا ان
تضعها نصب اعينها وهي تدركها تماما ان ليس
من حق اي دوله في العالم ان ترفض
قدوم او قبول اي شخص يكون على حدودها
ويطلب الدخول اليها خاصا اذا طلب اللجوء
هذه قاعده انسانيه ليس لاي دوله الحق في
عدم قبول اي شخص يطلب اللجوء اليها طبعا
البرلمان الاوروبي سينظر في بعض القواعد
التي وضعها هذا الاتفاق في مده الاحتجاز
تعتبر 40 تقريبا اسبوع مده كبيره جدا في
وضع احتجاز يعني حتى مده الاحتفاظ قانونيا
ووفق قواعد حقوق الانسان لا يمكنها ان تصل
الى مثل هذه المسائل سيتم تعديل هذا
الاتفاق مع مراعاه مراعاه جوهريه لحقوق
الانسان ولكن في الاخير سنعود الى نفس
النقطه ان كل هذه الاتفاقات لن تحد من
تدفقات الهجره غير النظاميه خاصه مع وجود
بؤر وحروب مثل السودان النيجر والجابون و
خاصه مع غياب التنميه داخل البلدان
الافريقيه ومع مواصله تجديد مراقبه الحدود
وخاصه مع مواصله ايضا رفض اعطاء الفيزا
للعديد من المواطنين هذا الاتفاق لن يصل
بعيدا وحتى وان طبق هناك محاكم دستوريه
اوروبيه سوف ترفض مثل القرارات التي
تتعارض مع حقوق الانسان واولها القاضي
الاوروبي الذي لا يحتكم لا للسياسات ولا
للحكومات ولا كل هذه الاتفاقيات بل يحتكم
فقط الى مراعاه والتقييمات الفرديه
الفرديه لكل وضع انساني داخل فضاء الاتحاد
الاوروبي وفق الاتفاقيات الامميه
والاتفاقيات الدوليه التي تراعي حقوق
الانسان شكرا جزيلا لك مالك الخالدي من
تونس شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من ميلانو خالد
شوقي ولضيفك من بروكسل هيلينا هان شكرا
لكم جميعا كالعاده ننتقل في نهايه هذه
الحلقه الى تغريدات في منصه اكس حول موضوع
هذه الحلقه نبدا بهذه التغريده لرئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه اورسولا فوندر لاين
جاء فيها ارحب بالاتفاق السياسي الناجح
الذي توصلت اليه الدول الاعضاء بشان مقترح
الازمه هذا تغيير حقيقي لقواعد اللعبه
يسمح لنا بالمضي قدما في المفاوضات بين
البرلمان الاوروبي والمجلس الاوروبي
وبوسعنا متحدين تنفيذ الميثاق قبل نهايه
هذه الولايه روبرتا متسولا وهي رئيسه
البرلمان الاوروبي قالت نستذكر اليوم 360
امراه وطفلا ورجلا فقدوا ارواحهم في
لامبيدوزا قبل عشر سنوات الهجره هي التحدي
الذي يواجه جيلنا لدينا طريق للمضي قدما
ويجب ان نتابعه سنكون عادلين مع من
يحتاجون الى الحمايه حازمين مع غير
المؤهلين
وصارمي مع الشبكات
الاجراميه رئيس الوزراء المجري فيكتور
اوربان الذي امتنعت بلاده عن التصويت
لصالح الاتفاق الجديد حول الهجره قال
المجر دوله ذات سياده لن نصبح جيتو
للمهاجرين ولن نتخلى عن حقنا في ان نكون
في ان تكون لدينا سياستنا الخارجيه
والاقتصاديه الخاصه مؤسسه انقذ الاطفال
الاوروبيه علقت على الاتفاق الجديد
الاوروبي حول الهجره قائله ميثاق اللجوء
والهجره في الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي تم
التفاوض عليه حاليا لا يمكن ان يبنى على
الردع يجب ان تكون الاولويه السياسيه هي
توفير الحمايه للاطفال وليس حمايه الحدود
الخارجيه منهم ونختم بهذه التغريده للفرع
الاوروبي لمنظمه العفو الدوليه والتي يقول
فيها وافق مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي على
لائحه الازمات التي تسعى الى تغيير
القواعد المتعلقه بكيفيه استجابه دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي للزيادات المفاجئه في
عدد الاشخاص الذين يصلون الى الحدود ومن
شانها اي هذه القواعد الجديده ان تخفض
معايير الوجوه التي تظهر ابحاثنا انها
تؤدي الى المزيد من انتهاكات
الحقوق بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد
وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا يتجدد
باذن الله الاسبوع المقبل دمتم في رعايه
الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء